thank you
it's 10 o'clock this is Sky News at 10
our top story taken for a ride over
illegal migration the government's
message to the public as the Prime
Minister promised to stop small boats
if you come here illegally you can't
claim Asylum you can't benefit from our
modern slavery protections you can't
make spurious human rights claims and
you can't stay
the former military bases where illegal
migrants may be detained and then
removed but we hear the opposition there
and in Parliament
and on the shores of northern France the
migrants who tell us they won't be
deterred and question whether there's
any legal way for them to get into
Britain also tonight
the final moments of a little girl gone
down in her home Olivia Pratt corbell's
murder has recounted by her mother
blowing the whistle on its Railway
strikes the Hardline unions suspending
industrial action tonight
burning coal to see off the cold why the
freezing weather has forced electricity
generators to use the dirtiest fuel
and we'll take a first look at
tomorrow's front pages that's in our
press preview from 10 30.
[Music]
hello there good evening the Prime
Minister said the current migration
system is unfair on the British people
today as he pledged to stop Small Boat
Crossings in the English Channel illegal
migrants could be held Out Of Reach of
the Courts for the first 28 days of
detention and in most cases wouldn't be
able to appeal until out of the country
the United Nations Refugee agency said
the government's plans amount to an
asylum ban tonight we'll look at the
barriers both legal and practical to
Rishi sunak delivering on his pledge and
here from migrants waiting to cross the
channel near Calais but first our
political correspondent Ali fortescu has
this report
we've got to somehow break the cycle on
the Kent Coast this morning a prime
minister determined to succeed where his
predecessors failed you can do it from
here yes as border Falls grapple with
thousands of Channel Crossings a bold
new plan to stop the boats if you come
here illegally you can't claim Asylum
you can't benefit from our modern
slavery protections you can't make
spurious human rights claims and you
can't stay
we will detain those who come here
illegally and then remove them in weeks
where do you think your predecessors
went wrong why are you different and can
I also ask what does success look like
to you will you be setting targets for
where you want the numbers to be in a
year's time so this is look not about
dwelling on the past because the
situation has just got far worse unless
we do something novel that we do
something bold to try and stop it and
that's what our legislation today does
now you know successes are stopping the
boats earlier in the day it was a Home
Secretary setting out a plan that may
well end up being defended in court I am
confident that this bill is compatible
with International obligations the
practicalities are enormous but the
message clear
for a government not to respond to waves
of illegal migrants breaching our
borders would be to betray the will of
the people we were elected to serve
their sense of fair play has been tested
Beyond its limits and they've seen the
country taken for a ride
Shadow Home Secretary but for labor it's
just more of the same
the Home Secretary has said anyone who
arrives illegally will be deemed
inadmissible and either returned to the
country they arrive from or a safe Third
Country
only that wasn't this Home Secretary it
was the last one
and that wasn't this bill it was the
last one passed only a year ago which
did not work
and there were moments of high emotion
that I will never vote for legislation
that would have led to my parents being
detained and dumped in Rwanda
the government wants immigration to
become a dividing line with labor at the
next election they know this is
traditional safe Tory ground that could
sway votes the trouble is it's not just
about talking tough on immigration it's
about delivery and there is no sense at
least in the short term that this
legislation alone can do that
his party are on side for now Rishi
sunak has gone further than his
predecessors but that doesn't mean he'll
stop the boats Ali fortescues Sky News
Westminster
well the illegal migration bill is
brought in its sweep and ambition it
would legislate a legal Duty for the
Home Secretary to remove anyone entering
the UK illegally the bill allows the
Detention of illegal arrivals without
judicial review for 28 days or until
they can be removed in 2021 the UK had
just over two and a half thousand
detention places that's at current
levels of migration less than 20 percent
of the capacity needed migrants won't be
able to use modern slavery laws to stop
their removal and challenges will only
be heard after they have left the UK the
Home Secretary told MPS she would not
yet address the full legal complexities
of the bill an annual cap on the number
of refugees being accepted by the UK
will be decided by MPS in Westminster
migrants arriving by illegal routes risk
a permanent ban on settlement
citizenship and re-entry to the UK our
communities correspondent Lisa Holland
reports now from Essex on the potential
impact of the plans
its thought sites like this isolated
former RAF base in Essex are being eyed
up by the government as places to house
large numbers of Asylum Seekers instead
of costly hotels
in nearby Wethersfield a pretty Village
People tell us they've heard rumors
unconfirmed the plan is for 1500 male
Asylum Seekers and they're not happy
they shouldn't be letting them anywhere
near us I don't think they should get as
far as being in this country to be
perfectly honest because they're coming
from other countries about 10 countries
why why do they all come right over to
us because we're soft touch this
approach of dealing that as an emergency
and panicking almost into selecting
locations that aren't appropriate away
from good accessibility good Services
local Services health health services to
schools
um just can't accommodate that kind of
scale of development
the government will hope the prospect of
being detained somewhere like this will
deter Asylum Seekers but it's difficult
to see how the threat to then Deport
them will be effective given that so few
have been successfully removed in the
past
Ali is from Iran and came to the UK by
small boat last year he says from
countries like his there's no
alternative way to claim asylum in the
UK what is the legal way do you think
that people who are danger in in their
home country can could go to any UK
Embassy and ask for Asylum no there is
no way to do that no one could choose
this dangerous way to travel and to left
his homeland to left his home country to
find nothing
whatever bold pledges the government is
making in reality a flight to send
Asylum Seekers to Rwanda last summer
never took off and the policy remains
stuck in the courts it doesn't explain
is where you're going to send them back
to so you have to have countries who are
willing to accept them at the moment we
only have six countries so what's going
to happen is where are these people
going to go and we haven't got the
return agreements we needed at least 200
return agreements with different
countries before we even attempt in
something like this
yet again the government is trying to
send a message that reaching Britain
won't be a dream come true for Asylum
Seekers the fact is no policy to date
has achieved that Lisa Holland Sky News
Essex
on the North French coast today migrants
we spoke to didn't know they were the
subject of another attempt to prevent
them Crossing one we spoke to said if he
was deported he would come back our
Europe correspondent Siobhan Robbins
reports
in the migrant camps in northern France
it's Mother Nature that calls the shots
many here are waiting to catch small
boats to the UK
today it was the weather which disrupted
those Crossings not an announcement from
Westminster
is they like most people we met was
unaware of the planned Crackdown his
wife is sick with cancer in the UK he'll
get to her any way possible
if you go on the boat you could die if
you get caught in the UK you could get
deported and never go back will you
still try
yes why because he's been
fed up I mean how long been separate my
five my wife my son how long I've been
separate I'm being ten years
the perilous Channel Crossings are often
the final leg of a long journey many
have fled War some have been abused and
beaten
but like 19 year old Afghan Jabba they
won't give up on their UK dreams
if they send us away we'll come back he
says and if they send me to Rwanda I
haven't committed a crime so I'll come
back
and today the criminal gangs controlling
this Shoreline seemed undeterred as we
filmed we heard deals for future
Crossings
breaking the trafficker's grip here
won't be easy Smugglers earn hundreds of
thousands of pounds controlling this
route one told us even if people were
sent to the Amazon they keep on trying
to get to the UK charity workers fear
tougher rules in the UK could make
Crossings riskier
I think there's a very good chance they
could get more dangerous people are
going to want to take risky routes to
try and go hidden and then there's going
to be high levels of exploitation when
they get to the UK because they're going
to be pushed underground in the UK
though many people feel like they've had
enough that the system's being abused
what's your response to that
unfortunately what the British public
have heard is not the truth and a lot of
the anger I understand but it's
misdirected because of misinformation
here the desperation feeds determination
and without more safe routes Smugglers
will keep on risking people's lives
Siobhan Robbins Sky News northern France
foreign
Street tonight and the government has
certainly set out its stall here Ali
throw in the kitchen sink even at the
small boats issue and the prime
minister's promise a big political risk
with no guarantee of success
yes and Anna I think it's worth saying
you know this is the Rishi sunac that
the government want you to see Talking
tough on immigration standing behind a
Podium branded stop the boats what has
been announced today is something new it
is something difficult it is something
pretty radical but as a prime minister
himself has said it's not the Magic
Bullet this is part of a kind of broader
strategy no coincidence he's going to
France at the end of the week to meet
the French President there are massive
practical challenges not least the
question with this legislation of how
the government would Deport and attain
thousands of people if it doesn't act as
a deterrent 45 000 people across the
channel last year 160 000 in limbo in
this country waiting for Asylum but
remember Rishi sunax pledged to stop the
boats is actually slightly more
complicated if you look at the text it
says that he wants to pass new laws to
make sure people are swiftly detained
and removed that is Rishi X pledge the
process has started today he says he's
ready for a fight with the courts but
actually stopping small boats well that
is something quite different
ly in Downey street thank you
a young girl shot dead in her home in
Liverpool screamed to her mother to say
she was scared to court her today the
final seconds before Olivia Pratt
corbell's murder were described by her
mother and read to a jury by prosecutors
the alleged gunman is on trial for
murder as our chief north of England
correspondent Greg Milam reports
seven months after her daughter's death
Cheryl corbell's own words describing
what happened that night were presented
to the jury in the trial of the man
accused of murdering her yeah
they heard how nine-year-old Olivia
Pratt Corbell had called out Mom I'm
scared before being shot in the chest
the prosecution say Thomas Cashman was
the gunman who took his pursuit of his
intended target that night into Olivia's
home and took her life who when that man
Joseph knee forced his way through the
door kept firing
David McLaughlin Casey told the jury
Cheryl said I was just screaming
screaming to go away and then I heard
the gunshot and realized I felt it it
hit my hand
she referred to Olivia as the baby I
remember when I turned round and
realized the baby was right behind me
because she'd come obviously come down
the stairs because she'd heard
one of the other children heard Cheryl
scream Olivia had been hit on the stairs
she told Olivia Stay With Me Baby
Olivia was pronounced dead in hospital
the prosecution say that's what this
case is all about the ruthless pursuit
of Thomas Cashman to shoot Joseph knee
at all costs without any consideration
of anyone else in the community the
result was that two people were wounded
and Mr McLaughlin said most tragically
of all that Olivia Pratt Corbell was
killed
after the shooting the prosecution say
Thomas Cashman went to the home of a
woman he trusted they say when she saw
the news about Olivia though she said
she broke down I couldn't protect him
she said she didn't want Olivia's mum
not to have answers
Thomas Cashman denies all the charges
the trials expected to last four weeks
Greg Milam Sky News
perhaps the most Hardline Union in the
public sector strikes this winter has
suspended action by some of its workers
tonight the rmt say they have received a
new pay offer from Network rail well our
business correspondent Paul Kelso is
with me now so another Union suspending
action uh what are the details of this
poll yeah the rmt has been in dispute
four months since last summer two
disputes one with network rail which
runs stations track signals one with the
train operating companies they say
they've received a new offer from
Network rail the last offer was five
percent pay rise this financial year
four percent next they rejected it there
is now a new offer on the table and as a
result they have withdrawn their strike
action I think we can look at the dates
that the strikes were due to happen now
the network rail dispute the strike day
the full strike day was the 16th of
March there you see next Thursday as
well as a single day strike action about
six weeks of overtime bans which are
hugely disruptive to the operation of
the network those have all been
suspended I'm told there will be a
referendum on this offer perhaps not a
full postal ballot the previous
referendum electronically done had a
recommendation to reject the payoffer
and the members did that we don't know
whether there'll be any recommendation
to go with this it should be said that
those strike dates have gone but the
other two dates you could see there the
18th the 30th of March as well as April
the first that strike action against the
train operating companies they remain
for now so there will still be strikes
on those dates but we are promised an
update from the rmt possibly tomorrow
there's been some pressure from the
employers they've said to the rmt look
if you're not going to even consider
putting this stuff to members we're not
going to talk to you so an attempt
perhaps call the unions Bluff plenty of
people have tried to call the rmt's
bluff in the past and found strikes
going ahead so we wait and see if this
is the start the start of a softening
from the rail Union okay Paul we'll wait
and see as you say thank you
Israel's prime minister Benjamin
Netanyahu says a gunman who killed two
Israeli Brothers In Cold Blood has been
eliminated it followed a raid by Israeli
forces on the West Bank Town of Janine
they suspected the Palestinian man of
shooting the brothers from a Jewish
settlement in huwara 10 days ago well
the violence in huwara itself has also
continued Skies Middle East
correspondent Alistair bunkel reports
from there
Israeli forces entered the Palestinian
town of Janine after an intelligence
tip-off that a wanted terrorist was
hiding there
they surrounded a building and a gun
battle broke out when the militants
refused to surrender
[Applause]
the Israeli soldiers killed the gunman
suspected of shooting dead two Israeli
Brothers in the Palestinian town of
hawara 10 days ago
the incident led to Violent rights in
the town and renewed tensions in the
west Banks
foreign
last night Israeli settlers attacked
hawara again they threw rocks at Shops
and cars including one with a young
Palestinian family inside
[Applause]
[Music]
she called me
she was crying what is
the matter she told me that is
I thought I was here I told you to close
the door don't open the door staying on
one of the room
before their issue we will be
there
Palestinian residents have now set up a
nightly neighborhood watch to try and
prevent further attacks
Israeli soldiers are still patrolling
the town but in fewer numbers
and Palestinians we spoke to said they
don't believe that they are being
protected by the military
do you feel safe here at the moment
actually nobody is here all people
around seven o'clock all people come and
start closing we ask him why we are
closing must not save here
the Muslim holy month of Ramadan is now
just two weeks away this year it again
coincides with the Jewish Festival of
Passover there is a growing fear that it
will be a particularly violent period
here and nothing has happened as yet to
avoid that
Alistair bunkel Sky News in the West
Bank
a vigil has taken place in Cardiff for
three people who were found dead in a
car crash two days after they went
missing
foreign
[Applause]
were found yesterday having been
reported missing following a night out
in the city on Friday two other
passengers remain in a critical
condition following the crash
an 11 year old boy has died in a fire at
a flat in East London firefighters were
called to the blaze just after three
o'clock this afternoon embarking four
other people including two children have
been taken to hospital
so Graham Brady has become the latest
prominent conservative MP to announce he
won't stand at the next general election
he's best known as the longtime chair of
the 1922 backbench committee which has
been Central in ousting the last three
prime ministers
well it is a stark reminder of how the
Russian State cracks down on descent a
student activist jailed for more than
eight years for using social media to
criticize the war in Ukraine before his
sentencing he told our Moscow
correspondent Diana magnet that people
in Russia had to fight their fear of
speaking out
a last Brave statement to the assembled
press in English he'd rehearsed with his
lawyer
understand that Russia is
and he didn't ask us about starting this
war with our closest Neighbors
23 year old Dimitri Ivanov sentenced to
eight and a half years in jail for
supposedly publishing fake news about
the Russian Armed Forces on his student
telegram Channel
reposts about alleged Russian war crimes
in mariupole and Butcher reposts of
President zelenski's accusations against
Russia
what message do you have to people in
Russia who are scared to speak out
in Russia is a fight with
this care and do what they can
[Applause]
his lawyer clapped outside the courtroom
for the work that she does but she says
it is impossible to bring Witnesses
refugees in Russia from Ukraine for
example to disprove these fake news
charges I I cannot re-traumatize them
with no guarantee of their safety
afterwards and would you therefore be
able do you think to use for example
witness tennis testimony of people who
are in butcher who are now in Europe
video witness testimony in in a Russian
Court they denied us to take us
inevident as evidence uh uh even
translated
investigations of New York Times for
example
uh translated reports of Amnesty
International
um
the UN report that Scott didn't take
even that
the only visible signs of protest in
Moscow over the past few weeks were
people leaving flowers here at the
Statue of a famous Ukrainian poet lecia
ukrainca
starting in January when a residential
building in nepro was bombed
people were detained but the flowers
kept coming for weeks after and again on
the anniversary of the war
when people ask why don't the Russian
people protest more well this is why
this is what having no freedom of speech
actually means endless detentions
endless Court hearings the Relentless
one-way March of Russian Justice
so most people do stay silent or they
look the other way because they know
that the state is watching and they know
what that means
[Music]
Sky News Moscow
for the first time ever tonight Britain
is burning coal as part of an emergency
scheme to deal with the surge in energy
use it's because of the combination of
the freezing temperatures low wind and
the pressure on gas supplies the
generating plants involved though are
due to be phased out by the end of next
year as our climate change and energy
correspondent hanette Thomas Peter
explains
as the coldest night of the year
approaches Britain is shivering Arctic
air dropping down from the north and set
to stay for days
it's putting pressure on our electricity
system the national grid for the first
time this winter activating emergency
coal units that have been standing by in
case of a shortage
the challenge we often face on very cold
days is getting through the short but
intense period of demand as everyone
gets home from work and school that's
millions of households putting the
kettle on turning the heating up and
making an evening meal all at the same
time
when it's windy we usually make more
than enough power to cover that but
right now it's relatively still
imports from Europe via subsea
connectors can also help but France a
major partner has had limited supplies
because of maintenance issues and
Strikes at nuclear plants
some of it was actually running through
the night last night Cole came to the
rescue this time but it is the dirtiest
of fossil fuels and has no future in the
UK's clean energy transition phased out
by the end of next year I'm actually
quite strongly against that we only
really have two Coal Power stations open
we do have a third this winter West
Burton but that's certainly going to
close in March I think it would be much
better to keep all of that open for as
long as possible and even to relax the
2024 dates I don't think that two Coal
Power stations are really moving the
dull when it comes to emissions but they
can be very important when we have
shortages such as the ones we're seeing
at the moment
this deep freeze a reminder that the
energy systems we rely on cannot be
taken for granted decarbonizing Power by
the middle of next decade as the
government has promised was never going
to be simple
Hannah Thomas Peter Sky News